the shaky science show clips
the other questions that i want to do is
kind of taking a bit of a side step is
the fact that on this channel a lot we
talk
i talk about um
targeting aging and finding ways to
target aging and effectively
age-associated diseases and um there's a
lot of work being conducted at the
moment in terms of looking at epigenetic
marks and its association with aging and
so i was just wondering what are your
current opinions on the potential for
precise epi genome editing by using
maybe crispr casting approaches for
example instead of having um the cast
iron fused to a
adenine based editor you instead have um
a d-methylase enzyme or an acid-base
enzyme or something completely different
right and and researchers have done
exactly what you've just described and
there are um multiple systems now
including one
just reported or being about to be
reported by
jonathan weissman and and the gilbert
and their their co-workers i think
jonathan has given a bunch of talks on
the topic so
i suspect he wouldn't mind uh me talking
about it
but uh the weissman system is called
crisper off
and it uses uh
it uses a
cutting incompetent cast nine like we
use in our base editors a dead cast nine
fused to a variety of very uh
carefully and and cleverly chosen
proteins
uh to
programmably turn off a whole region of
of dna
uh and it does so in a in a heritable
way in a way that's durable
uh which is really quite cool so it's
not as though you
necessarily have to
administer for the rest of the lifetime
of the organism or the patient
uh the the editing agents
to get a long lasting change in gene
expression
but i i generally agree that
that
targeted epigenetic modulation is
one of the
the great frontiers of
of this new
kind of
democratized programmable way of looking
at the genome
and in the interest of full disclosure
uh i
uh
i have co-founded a company in this
space uh called chroma medicine
uh with jonathan weissman
keith john and andrew gilbert so
uh to be transparent uh i i
certainly believe enough in
in the potential of of those systems uh
to be involved in trying to translate
that into patient benefit
cool and you mentioned one question i
was going to ask you about which is the
heritability of the fact that obviously
with genome editing it kind of makes
sense right if you've managed to edit
the genetic dna sequence it can get
passed on through the semi-conservative
replication to next cells but epi
genetic changes i just say it can be
questionable about whether or not they
would be permanent but um i think our
understanding of um the epigenetic is
improving all the time and um cell
states which pretty much governs which
genes are being expressed in different
cell types um and cellular reprogramming
going from a differentiated cell back to
a stem cell um are all things that
essentially could be mediated by just
making maybe a few precise epigenetic
marks that could propagate throughout
the rest of the cell i don't know what
your thoughts are right now i totally
agree and i i think one of the
one of the really cool scientific
discoveries of the past
few decades in my opinion have been
has been the discovery of ways that
epigenetic marks
are maintained over time
so that
changes to
the state of
dna modification or proteins that
regulate gene expression are not simply
modulating gene expression only at the
moment that they're installed
but rather
they can actually be passed down to
progeny cells as well
so
i mean in a sense it's
it's the core definition of epigenetics
that
you can
regulate
changes in biology
even that are heritable that don't
necessarily require changes in dna
and that that phenomenon is
is both
is both now pretty well established uh
is
is highly
uh relevant for treating
uh potentially uh genetic diseases as
well as doing a lot of cool research in
biology and genetics
and i think is poised to be one of the
the great new frontiers of
of the sort of programmable taking
control of our genome space
you